I don't even like to use the word
happiness but that's just a fleet and
feeling they can just go so up and down
I don't want to chase that feeling it's
just not an efficient way for me to live
I feel like just having peace and simply
just enjoying being alive every day is
the best place for me to be you know I
don't want to be happy and sad like I
don't even want to have to go through
that I just want to just kind of flow
through life I experienced so much I
just want to take on air experience for
what it is and enjoy it at the moment
you know so I don't want to chase
happiness just try to stay even it's a
journey that's better than a destination
it's cool for me to be who I am and be
and not apologize for it all the time
man I'm not coming out here unless I'm
100 I've never had no doubts of myself I
feel like I'm the best player in the
world I mean I feel as though at each
spot even in high school my game was
growing so fast I need to be in a
different environment to see how farther
I can go let's try to approach this in
an everyday Manner and you know try to
take it a day at a time you know I'm not
planning to do anything I'm just just
going to be myself
every day is a challenge to stay at this
level
that I'm at so I never looked at me
switching teams as a new challenge every
day I wake up I gotta fight against the
standard I set for myself I felt like it
was a time for a change that was never
my mentality ever always to win the game
and you know I appreciated people like
respecting my game but I wanted more for
myself when I dive into something like
that with that level of focus I don't
want to be anywhere else in life that's
the most enjoyable experience I ever had
after that first one try not to compare
I just uh each stop along the journey
has been I don't know I just been
tailor-made for the moment I guess you
know been learning a lot so far as a
player up until this point so I think
I'm starting to put everything together
out there on both sides of the ball and
I'm not looking at points or shots that
I get up it's just uh how focused I am
in each possession at one gym I might be
the best at another gym another guy
might be the best but it was just like
there's millions of gyms around the
world and this conversation is gonna
always keep happening and nobody's gonna
get the title all right so it's not no
need for me to even think about it but I
know what I bring to the sport I know
what I bring to the culture Sport and I
feel like I'm accepted by all the real
ones in the game you know what I'm
saying so that's really all that matter
I get that respect and that's what I've
been playing for yeah life is crazy you
know you can be on that high so fast and
in a matter of seconds you go back down
I'm grateful for it is is thought that I
had to go through but I'm also grateful
that I can experience it because down
the line I can be able to speak on how
much it helped me as a player and a
person I went through some adversity
right that's a part of life that's part
of this journey and I knew it it was
tough don't get me wrong but I never
wanted to quit I never thought I was I
got worse as a player I never thought
that so I wouldn't say it was a low I
just thought I had some adversity here a
couple bumps and the way I was raised
the way my mom raising my brother and my
dad they keep fighting and I just tried
to take that and apply into my everyday
life we respect the odds were stacked
against us single parent with two boys
by the time you were 21 years old
everybody told us we weren't supposed to
be here we moved from apartment to
apartment by ourselves
one of the best memories I had is when
we moved into our first apartment no no
bed no furniture and we just all sat in
the living room and just hugged each
other because we that's what we thought
we made it
when something good happens to you I
don't know about you guys but I tend to
look back to what brought me here you
wake me up in the middle of the night in
the summer times making me run up the
hill
making me do push-ups
screaming at me from the sideline of my
games at eight or nine years old we
wasn't supposed to be here you made us
believe you kept us off the street
put clothes on our backs food on the
table when you didn't eat you made sure
we ate you went to sleep hungry you
sacrificed for us
you're the real MVP
Family First communication is key I'd
like to thank God for changing my life
it really let me really realize what
life is all about
basketball is just a platform in order
for me to inspire people and I realize
that so many people believed in me when
I didn't believe in myself
so many people died of me
it motivated me every single day to be
who I am
I fell so many times and got back up
I've been through the toughest times
with my family you better I'm still
standing when you got people behind you
you can do whatever at the end of the
day I just focus on being the best that
I can be and adding it to the group
whatever that's the most important time
like personal time in the gym you know
you spend a lot of time with your
teammates and working through schemes
and trying to be a great team
and sometimes you can lose sight of you
as an individual trying to do all of
that stuff so when you're in the gym and
focusing on your craft and your skills
and how you can be your best to bring to
the team right that's I think that's the
that's what the game is to me you know
because we're all individuals trying to
bring something special to a group we're
here for a reason every team is looking
to get better saying we want to look to
upgrade and get better from where we
were I mean that's the this is the
progression of a unit you know so keep
building our identity that's the thing
and your identity comes from winning
basketball games regardless you know so
if you win basketball games you figure
out what your role is as an individual
and you kind of stick to that so never
jealous and no teammate ever well our
only goal is to be the best version of
ourselves every single day individually
and bring that together and work as a
unit and um outside noise from people
who are hoping that we fail hoping that
they see a show or get entertained by
some drama I mean we can't control that
stuff you know so we're just worried
about you know who we are individually
and then bringing that together as a
unit each and every day only the people
in this building matter
it means nothing to me because I still
got to get up and work on my game even
though I want to you know what I'm
saying so it's like that noise around me
don't stop talking like that like both
I'm the best player in the league I know
what I bring every night
no crying over spilled mountains about
how we can progress and get better from
here I definitely used to have crazy
anxiety wondering how I was going to
play the next day or in the next series
you know and it used to drive me crazy
you know what I'm saying and for my
mental health I guess is easier for me
to have this approach to just you know
waiting to see what happens and just and
then falling back on the work that I put
in you know what I'm saying and if I
fall back on that work then you know I
have to worry too much about what
happened I already know to come
naturally
try to play and try to try not to worry
about it
um if it happens it happens you know
sometimes when you tend to focus too
much on not getting injured you probably
go out there and get injured you know so
I'll just try to go as hard as I can and
live with the results and I see more
issues if we're not focused you know
what I'm saying if we're not locked in
or a game plan more so than anything
uh once we got a good game plan and you
know we follow it to the team you know
we understand that life is also bigger
than it so like I'm telling you to like
get your ass in the corner it's not that
I don't like you it's just that you know
that's what we need for this play to
work I wasn't expecting to be a happy
human being from a title I was just
expecting like you know the ending of a
movie Once you work so hard and
everybody tells you like yo this is what
you need to be working for it's just
gold ball in these rings and I'm just
like all right cool let me lock in on on
that and I locked in on wanting to
achieve that but I also realized it's a
lot of stuff that fact is in it that's
out of my control and once I won the
championship I realized that like yo my
view on this game is really about
development like how good can I be you
know I was just thinking like that man
so to hear all of this stuff about
I had ulterior motives and I was selfish
and I was just like that hurt more than
any and I was really opening myself up
and trying to build relationships with
everybody there so it felt like a slap
in the face but you know and then it
certain side of me was like well I'm
supposed to expect that like I don't
expect these people to be my friends
right that was my fault at the end of
the day so I shouldn't have opened up
that much I shouldn't expected them to
be
you know
cool and cool and be friends with me or
to do right by me you know what I'm
saying so yeah I thought I felt like of
course I felt hurt from it but
uh it's a lesson learned
when Talent fish to work hard
no matter how good you are if you don't
work hard nothing will happen for you so
always use that quote I instilled it in
myself that don't matter how good I am I
gotta keep working I mean hopefully I'm
setting a good example about how I
approach the game and hopefully I keep
inspiring people to play and watch the
game
[Music]